disculpa un segundo te importaría mirar
tu teléfono móvil un momento si pudieras
abrir la carcasa descubrirás algo
parecido a esto montones de microchips
pequeños transistores y circuitos
integrados pues bien para fabricar todo
esto hace falta un elemento muy concreto
el tantalio y de dónde viene este cantar
yo pues principalmente de un país la
república democrática del congo uno de
los países más pobres del mundo es
imposible estimar la cantidad de gente
que ha muerto para fabricar el móvil que
tienes entre tus manos el tantalio es
uno de los materiales más demandados del
mundo y el congo es el país con las
mayores reservas
podría ser una enorme fuente de riqueza
para este lugar un país que además tiene
muchos otros recursos naturales sin
embargo el congo es uno de los países
más pobres y más violentos del mundo y
creedme su historia es demasiado
compleja como para resumirla en un
artículo clic byte de estos que te
encuentras en twitter de vez en cuando
así que por qué es tan pobre el congo en
este vídeo te lo vamos a contar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el congo es un país del que solo has
oído hablar cuando vistes la película
gorilas en la niebla es curioso porque
por un lado nuestra cultura popular está
llena de referencias al congo pero por
el otro lado apenas sabemos nada de su
política
[Música]
hablamos de uno de los países más
grandes del mundo con más de 80 millones
de habitantes para que os hagáis una
idea toda europa occidental cabría en
este país seguro que todos habéis leído
alguna vez
tintín en el congo y de hecho en español
de españa todavía decimos que esto
cuesta un congo cuando queremos decir
que algo es muy caro y no es para menos
el congo tiene una auténtica fortuna en
recursos naturales caucho minas de oro
de cobalto y por supuesto de coltán que
es el mineral de donde se saca el
tantalio que usamos en nuestros móviles
[Música]
así que sin saberlo todos tenemos
productos congoleños en nuestra casa y
muchos dirían qué suerte verdad el con
gusta bendecido por los recursos
naturales pues es justo lo contrario
todo este oro cobalto y tantalio es
precisamente la maldición del combo
porque si mis queridos amigos de visual
política el congo es uno de los países
más pobres del mundo y hablamos de la
llamada pobreza absoluta
la mayor parte de la población vive con
menos de un dólar al día las hambrunas
son la tónica habitual y las guerrillas
son tan normales en este país que ni
siquiera se habla de ellas en los
telediarios pero todo esto ya lo sabéis
la pregunta es por qué y la respuesta es
que el congo es un catálogo de todas las
cosas que en visual polític decimos que
llevan a un país a la quiebra guerras
malos gobiernos corrupción a todos los
niveles y por supuesto colonialismo
imaginaos todos estos factores a escala
nacho vidal jana y tendréis una buena
radiografía de lo que es el congo bueno
pues ya está no ya sabemos por qué el
combo es tan pobre fin del tema por
favor esto es visual político el caso
del congo es único en la historia ni
siquiera lo podemos comparar con otros
países africanos y por eso es una
historia tan catastrófica como
fascinante
y si conocéis visual política ya sabéis
que hoy os vamos a contar todos los
detalles incluidos los resultados de sus
últimas elecciones así que la pregunta
es por qué el congo es tan pobre porque
decimos que sus recursos naturales son
su maldición y lo que es más importante
pueden cambiar las cosas con su nuevo
presidente hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia cómo privatizar un país en
el año 1877 el rey leopoldo segundo de
bélgica compró el congo así tal cual
como lo oís veréis cuando hablamos de
los procesos de colonización normalmente
nos referimos a que un país conquista
otro país es verdad pues aquí viene la
primera gran diferencia que hace único
al combo lo que conocemos como el congo
hasta ese momento es un territorio
poblado por distintas tribus un
territorio con muchísimo potencial para
plantar caucho que era necesario para
fabricar los neumáticos que se estaban
empezando a demandar en masa era un
material con muchísima demanda en ese
momento así que en cuanto el rey
leopoldo segundo descubrió todas estas
oportunidades de negocio
se le puso el símbolo del dólar en los
ojos y dijo para qué voy a colonizar
este país si lo puedo comprar
pensad que eran otros tiempos por aquel
momento las potencias europeas entendían
que podían hacer y deshacer en áfrica
sin pedir permiso a nadie por un lado
era una fuente de riqueza pero por el
otro entendían que la colonización era
una especie de forma de solidaridad una
forma de exportar los valores y la
civilización europea a una tierra de
barbarie y por eso
leopoldo segundo creo en bruselas la
asociación internacional africana
y
un organismo presidido por el que le
permitía ir al congo y establecer sus
propias fábricas y plantaciones de
caucho como los congoleños no entendían
lo que era la propiedad privada leopoldo
segundo se proclamó el dueño de todo el
territorio algo así como el que compra
unos terrenos en otro país solo que sin
ningún tipo de contrato por supuesto
para legitimar este saqueo leopoldo
segundo que no dejaba de ser el rey de
un país tan respetable como bélgica
decía que iba a convertir el llamado
estado libre del congo en un auténtico
remanso de paz y buenas costumbres
el estado libre del congo es un caso
único no tiene nada que esconder no
tiene secretos y solo está agradecido a
su fundador
leopoldo segundo rey de bélgica la
realidad era muy distinta
leopoldo segundo quería extraer el mayor
caucho posible y por eso esclavizó a la
población y les fijó cuotas de
producción imposibles si uno de estos
congoleños no llegaba a esos objetivos
se le cortaba la mano así es como
comenzó uno de los mayores genocidios de
la historia comparable en términos
relativos a la revolución cultural de
mao tanto es así que incluso otras
potencias colonizadoras como reino
unido- llegaron a denunciar al rey
leopoldo segundo por sus atrocidades
tras su muerte leopoldo segundo legó su
propiedad al estado belga y así es como
el congo se convirtió en una colonia el
gobierno belga fue algo más compasivo
con esta nueva colonia al menos de
sharon parte de las ejecuciones y las
torturas masivas pero los congoleños
mantuvieron sus condiciones de trabajo
esclavas veréis el colonialismo es una
de las prácticas más lamentables de la
historia pero si hay una potencia
colonizadora que ha destacado por su
brutalidad esa es bélgica y si queréis
'indignados' más todavía os diré que a
día de hoy bruselas todavía mantiene
edificios calles y monumentos en honor
al rey leopoldo segundo pero eso es otra
historia lo cierto es que en el año 1960
el congo por fin se independiza de
bélgica pero las cosas no fueron mejores
para este país su primer presidente
lumumba quería alejarse al máximo
posible de sus ex colonizadores cosa
lógica por otro lado y por eso tanto
bélgica como francia apoyaron toda clase
de revueltas cinco años más tarde el
urba era ejecutado y así es como empezó
la dictadura de mobutu sese seko y el
país pasó a llamarse zaire mobutu fue
uno de los dictadores más sanguinarios
de la historia sin embargo como solemos
decir en visual político mobutu era un
hijo de [ __ ] pero era nuestro hijo de
[ __ ] durante los tiempos de la guerra
fría el congo era aliado de estados
unidos y del mundo libre así que no
faltaba el dinero para financiar a su
ejército pero las cosas cambiaron en los
años 90
[Música]
sin una unión soviética- a la que tener
miedo eeuu dejó de apoyar a mobutu y
todos esos grupos a los que había estado
reprimiendo se rebelaron contra él así
es como comenzó la primera guerra civil
congoleña y el país volvió llamarse como
ahora esta guerra civil dio paso a la
segunda guerra civil congoleña y para
que os hagáis una idea esta segunda
guerra civil congoleña está calificada
como el conflicto más sangriento después
de la segunda guerra mundial más de 5
millones de muertos millones de
mutilados y toda clase de atrocidades
pero sabéis que es lo peor pues que la
violencia todavía no ha terminado
en el año 2003 se dio por terminada la
guerra y desde entonces joseph kabila ha
intentado ser el dictador que domina
este país con mano de hierro pero seamos
honestos por muy autoritario y corrupto
que sea joseph kabila es imposible
controlar este país por todas partes
encontramos guerrillas inclusiones de
países vecinos y señores de la guerra
sobre todo en la zona este que es donde
están los recursos naturales pero cómo
es posible que en un país tan pobre haya
tantos grupos armados de donde sacan el
dinero para comprar las armas pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver la fiebre del
coltán y os acordáis del famoso nokia
6110 salió al mercado a finales de los
años 90 fue uno de los primeros
teléfonos móviles de consumo masivo
mons johan andsjö pong de repente todo
el mundo todos tus amigos tenían un
teléfono móvil y eso significa que hacía
falta más y más tantalio para
producirlos
a ese momento el principal productor de
tantalio era australia el problema es
que conseguir este elemento era más caro
de lo que parece veréis es casi
imposible encontrar elementos químicos
puros en la naturaleza en este caso en
la mina australiana había unas rocas
donde tras un proceso químico
complejísimo podía sacar un poquito solo
un poquito de tantalio sin embargo hay
una forma más sencilla de obtenerlos y
amigos de visual político hablamos del
coltán el coltán es una roca con enormes
proporciones de tantalio y el refinado
de estas rocas es muy pero que muy
barato ya que no adivináis donde están
las mayores reservas de coltán del mundo
exacto en el este de la república
democrática del congo
básicamente el combo es algo así como la
arabia saudita del coltán hay mucho es
fácil de conseguir y fácil de refinar de
hecho ni siquiera hace falta tecnología
punta basta con que traigas un pico y
una pala para sacar tantas rocas de
coltán como si no hubiera mañana y por
eso miles de congoleños se lanzan
a la caza del coltán pero esperado
momento porque esto es sólo el principio
os acordáis de la crisis financiera de
2008 pues también tuvo algunas
consecuencias en australia
[Música]
can cierra la mina de tantalio de bobina
esta mina australiana era la principal
productora del mundo así que su cierre
supuso un subidón en los precios del
cantar yo es difícil estimar el precio
de mercado porque a diferencia del
petróleo no hay índices públicos que
muestran la cotización pero según
algunas consultoras hablamos de duplicar
su valor de un año para otro y qué
consecuencias tuvo esto para el congo
exacto la fiebre del coltán de repente
todo el mundo estaba dispuesto a jugarse
la vida por conseguir unas pocas rocas
sobre todo los señores de la guerra
[Música]
es decir que todas estas guerrillas se
financiaban con la venta de rocas de
coltán dicho de otra forma a mas
tantalio más violencia hablamos de tal
masacre que incluso eeuu tuvo que poner
cartas en el asunto
[Música]
y la propuesta de dodd frank se
convierte en ley básicamente esta ley
era un texto super extenso con medidas
para proteger a los consumidores
estadounidenses una de las partes se
refería a los llamados minerales
conflictivos y uno de ellos era el
tantalio según esta ley las empresas que
son tantalio tienen que saber de dónde
viene exactamente
de esta forma evitaría comprarlo a
señores de la guerra el problema es que
en un país como el congo es casi
imposible controlar la trazabilidad de
un mineral sobre todo teniendo en cuenta
que apenas hay empresas mineras hablamos
de gente normal gente que se lanza al
campo a recoger rocas y se las venden a
un señor que a su vez se la vende a otro
señor y que al final no sabes cómo
terminan en tu teléfono móvil en muchos
casos hay muchos mineros ruandeses que
cruzan la frontera explotan las minas y
después se en marchan de vuelta a ruanda
para procesarlo como sabéis ruanda es un
país que está creciendo muchísimo en los
últimos años y que sobre todo ofrece
muchísima más seguridad tanto física
como jurídica que el congo y si no lo
sabéis aquí tenéis un vídeo donde os lo
contamos
si os interesa conocer a fondo todos
estos temas sabéis que en visual polític
los cubrimos bastante a menudo así que
suscribiros a este canal y darle a la
campanita ya para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones pero vamos a
volver al combo muchos os preguntaréis
que siendo tan rentable como es que no
hay empresas grandes en el congo es que
no hay incentivos para extraer minerales
en masa pues lo cierto es que no queréis
un ejemplo pues aquí lo tenéis
la mayor minera del coltán del congo
reanuda su actividad tras bajar su
producción a la mitad en este caso es un
zoom es una de las pocas mineras que hay
en el congo la creó un senador congoleño
que quería industrializar la minería en
lugar de extraer el coltán jugándose la
vida
vissum su quiero utilizar máquinas de
esta forma no solamente mejoran la
seguridad de los trabajadores sino que
además pueden extraer mucho más mineral
y de forma sistemática el problema pues
primero que todas estas máquinas son
caras y el dinero escasea en un país
como el congo hablamos de inversiones
muy caras que requieren un montón de
estabilidad jurídica pero entonces es
cuando llega el segundo problema los
políticos corruptos y si tu problema no
es la corrupción entonces no te
preocupes el tercer problema son todas
esas guerrillas que te van a asaltar te
van a robar el coltán y pueden destruir
sus fábricas conclusión porque casi
ninguna empresa está dispuesta a
invertir las que lo hacen tienen que
parar la producción cada dos por tres
[Aplausos]
y aquí es donde llegamos al círculo
vicioso sobre el coltán cuanta más
demanda existe más incentivos hay para
que los señores de la guerra lo quieran
explotar y cuantos más señores de la
guerra explotando en cortar menos
incentivos hay para crear una industria
que de trabajos de calidad y apoye el
país todo esto explica que pese a que
tanto el congo como los países vecinos
producen la mitad el tantalio que se
consume en el mundo el pib del congo
apenas ha crecido en las últimas décadas
y os preguntaréis hay alguna oportunidad
para que cambien las cosas pues puede
que sí pero también puede que no ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el gran fraude recordáis a joseph kabila
el dictador del congo pues bien en el
año 2018 dejó su cargo y convocó
elecciones en realidad según la
constitución congoleña tendría que
haberlo hecho mucho antes pero bueno ya
sabéis cómo son los dictadores y cómo os
podéis imaginar las elecciones de 2018
tenían más trampas que una escopeta de
feria las provincias más contrarias a
kábila sólo tenían uno o dos colegios
electorales y el voto se hacía a través
de unas tablets que nadie sabía manejar
vamos que ningún observador
internacional aceptó este proceso
el combo a la unión europea ocúpate de
tus asuntos están a punto de celebrar
unas elecciones que han sido pospuestas
por dos años y el país ha echado al
embajador de la unión europea pues bien
en estas elecciones había tres
candidatos importantes de amazon y era
el sucesor de kábila fai hulu que era el
opositor y si se quería que era el que
menos posibilidades reales tenía pues
bien a que no adivinan quién ganó pues
no no gana razón y ganó chiste que di y
ahí es donde surge el debate porque
según todas las organizaciones que han
observado las elecciones incluida la
iglesia católica el proceso no ha podido
ser más sucio
[Música]
según muchos analistas camila sabía que
nadie iba a aceptar que ganara su
sucesor así que le dio la victoria a un
opositor moderado que al menos le
permitirá mantener su fortuna no
olvidéis que aunque tongo sea tan pobre
tras años de dictadura y perder ruta
kabila es millonario
sin embargo donald trump apoya a que se
quede aunque sólo sea por garantizar un
gobierno mínimamente estable para el
congo pero la pregunta es pueden cambiar
las cosas con este nuevo presidente pues
lo cierto es que oportunidades no le
faltan
limpio y tantalio la nueva producción
australiana de pilbara básicamente los
australianos han descubierto un nuevo
modo para producir cantar yo de forma
barata y eso significa que han podido
reabrir su mina y esto qué consecuencias
puede tener para el congo pues -7 coltán
para los congoleños lo que significa
menos dinero para las guerrillas y más
incentivos para crear empresas éticas y
con procesos industrializados por otra
parte ruanda el país vecino ya está
desarrollando su propia industria de
refinería del coltán en 2018
construyeron una enorme fábrica para
producir tantalio incluso están
empezando a experimentar con la
tecnología block change para poder
estudiar la trazabilidad del tantalio es
decir que si esto funcionará todo el
mundo podrá saber cómo y de dónde viene
el mineral que compra pues bien este
nuevo gobierno congoleño tiene ahora la
oportunidad de asociarse con sus vecinos
para crear una industria de coltán que
de verdad genere empleos y riquezas
[Música]
pero ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
creéis que están dispuestos a hacerlo de
verdad este nuevo presidente congoleño
va a acabar con la corrupción reinante
para sacar a su país de la pobreza os
seguiremos viendo como el pongo se
empobrece día tras día pese a tener
tantísimos recursos naturales podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios
it's no os vayáis todavía que antes de
terminar tengo que darle las gracias a
susan de eroski por ayudarme con la
investigación rosquín es una de las
principales consultorías de minería del
mundo y han sido muy amables con
nosotros han contestado a todas nuestras
preguntas y nos han facilitado un montón
de información que de otro modo habría
sido imposible de conseguir porque no
está disponible para el público general
y también gracias a marti df de ciencia
que me ha estado ayudando un montón para
entender el mundo de las rocas el
tantalio y el coltán té de ciencia es
uno de los mejores canales de ciencia de
todo youtube así que si no lo conocéis
deberíais echarle un vistazo y como
siempre si os ha gustado este vídeo
dadle a like y nos vemos en el próximo
un abrazo y hasta pronto